Last week I posted a video where I said
my husband and I are not equal partners in our marriage.
This sparked a lot of comments
trying to point out to me that I'm not any less because I'm a woman
or because my husband is the main bread winner.
These folks were so worried about me being subservient
and less than my husband,
but the statement that I made was completely ungendered.
This society seems to be so worried about misogyny,
but they immediately jump to the conclusion that
if my marriage is not equal,
then it must be I,
the woman, who is less important.
So who has internalized misogyny now
to really prove that we are about Equality?
Half the comments should have been worried for my husband.